each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
so
afternoon everyone it's the traditional
five minutes past the hour so we can
start today we have professor kinda
Thomas Wong from Hong Kong polytechnical
Polytechnic University he is associated
professor there but took his bachelor's
degree in university of california los
Los Angeles and his PhD from Purdue
University he is going to talk today
about acoustic velocity sensors and what
kind of beam forming and sound capturing
we can provide with them without further
ado what was your hand before as I as I
mentioned my talk is about acoustic
sensor array the objective we here's the
point the objective we have is its beam
forming and specifically we are going to
do frequency invariant beamforming what
I mean by that is said that what i mean
by this term is set up in formal weights
do not depend on frequency do not depend
on the frequency of all the incoming
signals of the incoming interference of
the frequency of the noise and we can
real light this because of a special
kind of sensor that we are going to use
not Michael Fong not the UL a uniform
linear array not uniform circular rape a
special kind of microphone a special
kind of sensor caught the acoustic
velocity sensor try it so basically we
have three velocity sensors in this
system okay so this is the presentation
of my talk so first what is what is a
velocity sensor triad what is
advantageous for beam forming and how
about some specific algorithms for
adaptive beamforming using velocity
sensor try it now adaptive beamforming
different people you
term to mean different things what I
mean here is not being pattern not space
on Matt filtering but some part of the
data model is unknown to the algorithm
and changes over time so the algorithm
itself adapts to the external
environment and then there'll be some
data for jury trial using simulated
speech data this presentation is
actually based on a paper just appear
last month in JSA okay so what is the
velocity sensor try it ok now this is
the array manifold the array manifold of
a velocity sensors triad so we actually
have three components in a triad this is
the measurement model if the source
comes in with elevation angle theta and
azimuth angle Phi this will be the
measurement I mean the array manifold
now notice that the UVW turns out to be
just a direction cosine along the x axis
along x axis along Y excellence' along
the z axis so this is just that this
just that this is just that this is just
a property of the velocity sensor and we
have three of them okay now notice some
interesting properties about the array
manifold the array manifold depends on
elevation angle and also depends on SMS
angle very importantly no frequency no
wavelength here unlike the uo a uniform
linear array or uniform circular array
now this array manifold is applicable
for far field the sauce we're far away
or the source relatively close by to the
sense itself but again there's
out here the out the separation between
the emitter and the sensor does not
appear in the array manifold now this
would be those those properties the
poverty of F does not appear and how
does not appear would be really really
advantageous for adaptive beamforming as
we will see in a min in in a moment okay
let me just skip over this page let me
show you a picture of the velocities
okay just just say e so it is relatively
simple arm the velocity sensor for a
acoustics is actually commercially
available for example by a company in
Illinois and this is the spec sheet just
download from the company website
vertical axis just magnitude response
horizontal axis is just frequency so
according to the spec sheet it has pre
constant response from a hundred hers to
about maybe three to four kilohertz
within 3 DB so this kind of inexpensive
the lottery sensor will be good enough
perhaps for speech processing but this
is just one example there are the kind
of commercially mode commercial models
available for velocity sensor a
professor from the University of
Illinois urbana-champaign actually just
have a do-it-yourself kind of vector
sensor so this is one two three velocity
sensors and one Michael phone so the x
is x axis is here y axis would be here z
axis would be here so they do not
exactly co-locate but relative to the
wave things they are almost collocated
now in here there's an optional pressure
sensor here it is optional
now but they are actual actually
commercially a commercial products
available for the Becca sensor one
doesn't have to do it yourself this is
at a company in the levins this is a
picture i downloaded from the company
website according to the company the
frequency range from one tenth of hers
to 20 kilohertz so that's the hearing
human hearing range for a very young
person within one DB that's what the
company claims so the velocity sensor
triad is practical it is commercially
available it's been implemented we can
actually buy it what we have been
talking about is for a acoustics but
actually the a lot of sensor has a long
history going back over a century
according to some reference are going
some books but mostly has it roots in
underwater acoustics for defense
purposes so this is just underwater
acoustic version of the wrecked
hydrophone this is just external case so
the black thing is just the support for
example a boat mate Oh an array of this
kind of back to hide your phone behind a
boat or behind a submarine okay so okay
so so far we see that the velocity
sensor Schreier is already available if
we have money just going by so what r is
advantages well we hinted on it a while
ago the advantages lies in the
simplicity of his arraignment for
simplicity in the sense that it is
independent of frequency and independent
of our now when we say independent
frequency and I've got this is an
idealization when we're looking at that
product manitou responds you know it
domenica just drop off after four
kilohertz and so on
but it is independent of frequency in
the sense that since the three
components are the same so the drop-off
would be sort of similar for the three
in that sense it is independent of
frequency so there are actually four
advantages that I'm going to talk about
the first two are really simple we
already mentioned it we mentioned the
first one already one unit the picture
from Michael flown one unit women wear
tiny unit give us SMS and also elevation
angle it doesn't have to in ula spread
out on in a rate grid it can be very
very compact it can be very very compact
so the third advantage is what i would
like to dwell on a little bit longer the
array manifold does not depend on
frequency so when we do beam forming the
beamformer ways also do not have to
depend on frequency we can make it to
depend on frequency okay but you know
that's just optional but we the
Performing wait do not have to depend on
frequency now this is in contrast to an
ula ula a linear ray of uniformly spaced
Michael foams omnidirectional pressure
sensors if we just consider the first
three it is just a three element ula
then this would be the ula array
manifold familiar to I think most of us
the frequency appears to the wavelengths
here so if we have the ula have a look
direction of 30 degree and if we set the
beamforming wait to be for two kilohertz
that's this is the speed of sound in air
and then we do okay and then we we plot
the
the space of match filled up in pattern
well if it is exactly at two kilohertz
we got a purple one and that is right
because we get a peek at 30 degrees we
set at 30 degrees but if the frequency
is 500 Hertz very much within the human
speech range the peak migration Tiffany
to left such that it at 30 degree you
know it is the actually has a valid
attenuated military response and if the
frequency rises to 3.5 kill occurs at
the 30 degree we again we have only 175
and so on so basically what I try to
show here is that for you la or similar
kind of setup you see a you are a
uniform rectangular array things like
that because the frequency appears in
the array manifold we really need to
have a lot of signal processing to
account for the array manifolds
dependency on frequency
okay this just for a l-shape array
similarly the the frequency appears
through the wavelength and I just give
this example because for this l-shape
array we can do the azimuth angle as
well as the elevation angle but still
the frequency appears so if we have a
beam pattern have a look direction of
elevation angle 30 degree and as SMS 30
degree at a frequency of two kilohertz
then this would be the beam pattern but
then if using the same beam forming
weights a frequency 500 the pimp energy
changes quite a bit and if the frequency
now become 400 amina for 4,000 Hertz the
beam pen again are quite different now
this is the intended location of the
peak but here where the peak should be
we actually get Sullivan now so the
frequency dependency of the array
manifold could be a really big problem
in fact that they are not co-located
and this is related to the fact that you
set up your time delay attraction in
fiction which is
just use x suppose to face that
if right so too so the reason we have
this conv nominee is because the
pressure sensors are not co-located and
if as you mention if we do not use face
but if we use time then it would be
wideband processing and the time and it
in and the direction we be coupled
together before the AVL for the record
sensor the look direction and the
frequency axis can be decoupled so we
can handle the two separately and that
give us more versatility what is a
problem ok you have estimated that
d'Alene some weights from the two
thousand heads and that's fine but if we
talk visas this is more processing in
the frequency we made we can estimate
the proper waits for every single
frequency been I then you'll help pretty
much a quiet night before are always the
maximum will be able to desired location
this is not a substantial amount of
competitions which is a problem for what
lobo we'll see you today I would agree
with you that this kind of system can be
can be can be used for the way you you
mention it now if it is adaptive signal
processing you know if some of the
interference or sources are moving
around and if you want the cpu to be
really really inexpensive and really
cheap so that would be Becca sensor
would be one alternative so exactly you
know how shape a cpu is chip enough I
think that a system development question
so you know you know much much more than
I and I do it I suppose it Polly depends
on how she was sure enough and also how
adaptive the performing
need to be
did you make a pressure
right so the the poppet oh my i guess
it's called acoustic particle velocity
field better particle velocity field
vector sum one way to measure actually
we're going to measure lee one more okay
charm a basic a little bit one way to
measure measure it is to have two
microphones and then do a first all the
difference that's one way and other ways
do it in to measure the velocity
directly by optical methods by thermal
methods and also by other mechanical
methods as well even though you can't
conversation
just acquisition in your bottom
sometimes you get you have to make a lot
more to dynamic system and the funding
capture that it calls with the you know
the frequency effects at the Centers
effects there too there is confidential
and another fool for some applications
the interference can be I mean I mean
some of the sources may we have a known
frequency band maybe it is not speed you
just some something else for example
when one thing this thing is useful is
to detect sniper so when we detect any
unexpected sound that would indicate
something abnormal or that should not
happen is happening so if part of so
suppose about the size signal is indeed
human speech but we do want to you know
we check some impulse interference that
is is this frequency band maybe as some
unknown location the Avs might give us
some additional versatility
yeah so I would totally agree that the
davs is not categorically superior but
it offers some positive and also some
negative the weather AVS is relevant for
particular product it really is system
development judgment okay so basically
we because as we decouple the look
direction from the frequency axis so it
could be computationally simpler if we
use the vector sensor okay so this
actually I've been just mentioned we
mentioned it okay so it reaches for
speech music and background noises as
faithful music and background noises
they are there they're really broadband
and depend with maybe it unpredictable
locations and that band width varies
over time and typically a priori unknown
so if we can decouple the look Direction
coordinate from the frequency
co-ordinate it might give us some
additional advantage so the velocity
sensor try it which I sometimes called
the the vector sensor okay its beam
pattern does not depends on app and
that's what it's not be depends on now
okay so here's another advantage is that
if we look if we look at the ula if it
is near field and if R is the distance
between the Demeter and the sensor the
arraignment will actually would you
cannot now but for the velocity sensors
try it out does not appear yeah so
that's another advantage is that the
same pin pattern can be used regardless
of how far we are how close the emitter
is from the front of it from the from
the sensor system
okay so how about using the velocity
sensor trier for adaptive beamforming I
guess many people here are actually been
from a beautiful make special
artistically really quick so this is a
scenario in my subsequent discussion so
it's a conference room they're
potentially up to six simultaneous
active speakers potentially so the
sensor in this case is put at the top of
the ceiling it doesn't have to be clear
but this is just the simulation scenario
i have for the subsequent pages so this
just the the collected data at time T so
let's say particular speaker is the
desired speaker and then I have on that
diagram Carol I would be 55 interviewing
speakers and some noise so i form the
three times three spatial covariance
matrix Y three well why three times
three because we have a try it we are
three velocity sensors so we have three
times three so this is just the minimum
power distortion last response
beamformer some people may be a little
bit unfamiliar with this terminology but
it's basically minimum variance
distortion nurse responds that the only
difference is that in mb/d all this is
supposed to be the actual real data
community this supposed to reflect the
real statistics in mvd all but in MPD
out this is just the the empirical
collected data but this is the idea
behind it is basically the same as envie
dr so in MV dr beamforming the way
vector here would ensure no distortion
at this look direction the tuned
direction while minimizing the beam
farmers overall output power
now remember in a try it we only have
three sensors we have a very stressful
situation here we have the desired user
the group the blue purple thing here ok
this is the azimuth angle that is the
elevation angle and we have five
interferers so we actually have six
people talking together at the same time
so this is a very stressful situation
and the left hand side the right hand
side are basically the same thing but
it's just a contour map now the SOI
admittedly is not at a peak but if you
look at them now if you look look at the
no 1 now hear another know what it knows
the two notes are placed sort of nearby
the five interference so so the
beamformer would actually help the SI in
out the signal to interference and noise
ratio I emphasize that this is a very
stressful situation because we have more
emitters then we have sensors which is
three now I also have their milk you
know my gracious stay at church how many
scenarios and this is the best looking
one
okay this is just to summarize the the
advantage of using the velocity sensor
triad one set of beamforming wait for
all frequencies one set of informing
ways without regard to how close by the
speaker is one set of beamforming wait
regardless of the interfering sources
distance from the sensor system no need
for any prior information of the
time-frequency structure of the signal
and all of the deciding no end of the
interference so simplicity would be is
primary advantage now where this
simplicity is is worthwhile in any
particular system there would be a
system development kind of judgment
right yeah okay now how about if the the
look direction is unknown well there's
something called music music has nothing
to do with music it is just an acronym
it's a parameter estimation method so
through this kind of method we can
actually ask me the design looks
direction the assumption behind this
method is that a decides beaker is
actually loudest which I hope is the
case I and less ability try to show down
the Desai speaker so we can see that
that the vertical axis is the estimation
bias in degrees so this is one degree so
in this particular scenario if the SI s
I in now this interference present if
the SI n now is sort of like you know 10
15 DB then it could be the estimation
can be corrected within one degree
now how about is if that music method
does not estimate to precisely or if the
velocity Center try it is tuned by some
machine or human but tune in precisely
what would happen well so that's the
problem of Miss pointing the beamformer
if the beamformer is Miss pointed I'm
sorry I don't have the numbers with me
on this slide but I have the numbers in
the paper I have then you know the
desired user could in deep in node but
there's a method called I a signal
processing method call diagonal loading
it's a very simple method to set an
extra identity matrix here scaled by the
loading factor gamma then arm the beside
speaker will not be note anymore
according to the papers that i have read
and i try to read Musel paper there it's
kind of ad hoc they don't have a theory
for it so i guess if it a certain kind
of application scenario people would try
ahead of time you know what range would
typically work for this person class of
scenario and of course the right hand
side diagram Mike register has tried
many many ways of gamma and he finally
this would look the best if used sound
source localization system uses given
set of sensors and makes a mistake isn't
it better to make the same
I going to do the captioning so if the
localizer thinks that the sound source
is right there most probably when you
formed an even if this is not the
correct location most probably the
Deepwater should point when the system
thinks is because by services the
sensors are not identical we better
point to the appointed get results I
think the pointing error may come from
many different causes maybe the cost
that you mention is that the array
itself is not calibrated such that when
when you see incorrect maybe I don't
know maybe what you mean is the correct
is the nominal if the array is perfectly
calibrated is ideal is ula all these
senses are isotropic you cocaine and
exactly space at half wavelength or
whatever so it's a perfect idealized
version then it hasn't been forming of
vector and then the actual physical ula
that we have which will be uncalibrated
the microphones may not have you go gang
they may not be located at a correct
nominal position then that ideal at that
non ideal ula would give us another
setup informer wait so we should not try
to make the two to equal that I would
totally agree that I would totally agree
but the Miss pointing here is a
different kind of Miss pointing it is
that it doesn't matter at this can be
spawning is would exist whether we have
the ideal ula or we have the
uncalibrated imperfect ula but just
somehow the me because the music
algorithm or other kind of parameter
estimation algorithms has bias as buyers
and the buyers could be quite
significant if the SI n now is is it's
bad enough or if the tuning is actually
done by a by person and the person will
be a little bit sloppy and do not tune
manually to the correct direction
so I'm talking about different kind of
Miss pointing not because of the array
is calibrated or not so even if the
array is calibrated the algorithm could
have estimation bias because of noise
because of interference because other
economies are the kind of imperfections
ok now the jury trial is not very
realistic I would be first to admit okay
I did not actually have the money to buy
for Michael Fong that system and my
graduate student they're trying to build
it but it's still building it so the
amplifier is not that easy to do
apparently so what we do is for the
signal publishing a paper is that we
just downloaded some file from the
internet people reading news the sphere
reading some book or something and
basically just put them into the data
model here and then do the signal
processing now the jury is real there
are actual humans so what's the jury
says the evaluation system is from a
scale of 0 to 10 so it is 11 possible
marked if it is 0 1 2 or 3 it would be
totally unintelligible it is seven eight
nine ten it would be totally
intelligible but of course you know 10
speech would be would have very good
sound quality beyond intelligent being
intelligible so here i have a 50-member
jury vertical axis is the average score
horizontal axis is the SI and out in
into the beamformer i have got three
curves the iso is the isotropic single
sensor just ones not you are a just one
sensor the black one this thing is the
abs but using space on match filtering
just based on match filter to have a
look direction look at the Desai speaker
the interference will not affect the SMF
beamforming wait the
interference will affect the SMF beam
from an output but not to be informal
ways the MPD are as expected would have
the best performance a smell when
the single microphone and the matched
filter Vivian's are both basically 01
the speech is already intelligible
because it's seven now in that this is
the case for three speakers remember we
have a triad so three speakers three
speakers including the decide speaker so
decide speaker + to interference this
case we have the side speaker and five
interference so it's very stressful
still the MPD I'll give us a little bit
of help by a bus golf one but because
the situation is really stressful so
again over the spatial measuring is just
a tesco of one but keep in mind is a
very stressful seizure six speakers
simultaneously active it just white
Gaussian additive white Gaussian noise
and generation you guys put so much
also so you can see that this is a no
reverberation case noble aberration so
it is really not very convincing but
this is solidly just to show that at
least under this very ideal situation
there could be some improvement can we
hear it or what it sounds like
unfortunately um when I was coming today
I just remember that you know I should
put the design samples in it because
we're talk about speech I actually do
not have the papas time symbols on my
laptop and also because this is done in
Hong Kong the time symbols are in
Chinese because the students you know
with limited English fluency so I don't
want the English in language problem BB
effect into it and it's much easier to
find people to listen to Chinese pitt
union hall so unfortunately I don't have
it yeah I should have it but I i don't
i'm sorry but but this is really a a toy
scenario i totally agree Casillas
friended Yasi didn't know
does not happen to source
why does one
I told her I fear is a very good
criticism you know I mean academics so
my visa is just popping in papers my
boss will be happy with it so probably
reason I kind of micro solve it perhaps
to learn from you guys what kind of
realistic polymer should deal with ya
for reverberation to develop a system we
really need to look into that before
publishing a paper just have type toy
scenario could get through and
fortunately yeah on the other hand the
reverberation you know in a way it is a
somewhat different dimension as because
the purple of this paper is just to
demonstrate that this kind of realizes
try it can separate the frequency
dimension and the radial dimension from
the look direction that was actually the
the only thesis in this paper so there
are lot of questions not addressed by
this paper I totally agree yeah so in
general you use the theoretical model of
the gradient sensors assuming that
they're perfectly identical how robust
or sensitive is this particular
implement
MPD other before going to the channel is
much hope you do right I have a research
work in progress with a mathematician
they look exciting to that problem is
that how about if the channel mismatch
there are many kind of mismatch the gain
the phase and the location may I mean we
have an an array of such triads the
tribe may not be at is nominal location
and if I have to try as how bout of the
orientation not identical I mean just
just having to shift by 1 or 2 degree I
mean it's possible then how would it
degrade performance so I have a research
on going with a mathematician and we
model that mismatch statistically that
if the game the game is match has a say
bias of zero but that means marriage is
stochastic but is Gaussian distributed
then how would it affect the direction
finding how would affect beamforming so
we want to have we were trying to derive
a nice and beautiful equation that show
as what the exact degradation is so we
were given for the six people tears of
the left champion it shows that you guys
have a correct implementation
we are being PDR before God and with
three microphones it can place Paul
towards the desired direction into nose
towards the to undesired speaks perfect
but then once you go to multiple
speakers even up when I have multiple
speakers fabricating more than other
houses of the six speaker scenario then
even at this case i would go with
processing kid frequency Romanian
estimation the mvd are being former
weights / frequency been the reason for
this is that speech is a very sparse
signal and nuclei have six speakers
talking but it's unlikely to have six
speakers in the same frequency bins of
each frequency bin processes separately
with frequency dependent weights will
adaptively place the null stores that
those two speakers which I was happening
to camp energy and ebony you can convert
the speaks speak a scenario into the
results of the art a speaker scenario
right I would I create that would be an
alternative I mean there would be a very
good method the tray off so it is very
simple here I mean it of the computation
so it's that simplicity worthwhile you
know it depends on the system
development philosophy I guess so it may
not be worth while well it might be well
that depends on these specifications not
much of the CP required 81 mobile phone
to dick and drive at least 10 of those
big hopes of an easy a lil time haha ok
you can't dual-core CPU which is the
police tables ok ok ok
and of course but innovation will spill
the results like a family
so I come and see the doc kinda started
to begin a discussion so feel free to
interject and ask questions please I
have a question about me the
low-frequency performance if you are to
make a practical if you buy my missing
as a measure of the velocity particle
velocity it's measuring is proportional
to the gradient of pressure which makes
it much more sensitive to if you had a
source that can produce a constant
pressure amplitude and sweep across
frequency it's going to be much more
sensitive at the high frequency and
because you've got a much greater
pressure gradient if you wanted to make
a wideband be former maybe seven or
eight operatives that means somewhere
along the chain you had to have a
conversation of maybe 50 DB in other
words you've got to boost the low
frequencies by 50 DB release into the
very high frequencies so that's going to
limit your low frequency performance and
it's all also going to be limited by the
noise now as I understand that these
devices are made by having a heated wire
and measuring the v8 loss I'm not too
sure about how to try to do so works
it's very noisy process which pleased
that you're limited on your low
frequency posted do you have any any
comments on how practical these are ways
I really don't have any comment on earth
my background is really signal
processing so I don't know much about
those implementation issues yeah so
that's like a total McCool all I can see
is a pretty much of 10 millimeters pipe
with the time time you're worrying like
to which is really heated with the
current and then they measure the
equinox which means how cool or hope is
the one that's it as that's proportional
to pressure gradient yes and if you help
to encourage the frequency response as
they show you have to push pretty much
60 min per octave get felt which is a
lot for pro back
so it's not really frequency very its
frequency invariant over a bandwidth
that's very kind of immunizations yeah
thanks for the comment i really don't
know much about him physical how we
implemented behind it but i think that
dick I know that would be a very
interesting research topic for a signal
person signal processing person like me
how to correct for it by signal
processing using stereo microphone
arrays we're using not measuring the
pressure in one point the group
measuring it at some distance away from
the central recording system and that
helps to deal with other frequency
programs ok hey thanks for coming so
still considering the scissor per se if
you have a sensor switch our place it on
at least certain distance let say we go
to 8 kilohertz that's around four or
five centimeters so you can help them at
this couple of centimeters the sensors
away then in this case you can use the
differences in the time of arrival in
the phases with this particular design
you put the sensors close to each other
which means that you the only q you have
for the direction of arrival is the
magnitudes because their senses have a
very specific purpose can you come into
this what will you gain and what we lose
I haven't really compared the two
different approaches
one obvious thing is that the time
difference of a rifle would need to have
more than one location here's just one
look at that point is very obvious for
computation power you know you mention
it's not a big factory at all I I don't
know if the AVS I mean this method would
save a little bit of computation power
not however unimportant that saving
might be well if distance we can use
both the differences in magnitude seeing
in the vase the moment you put them
together the only q you have is the
magnitude that's it and this pretty much
limits whatever the reactivity pattern
you do with the first order elective ET
partez so the best you can do is
hyper-connectivity pattern if you cover
isotropic ambient noise field mm-hmm
that's it well with a four-element
microphone today you can go a little bit
further than there right at the
directivity pattern here arm I don't
know what you might have in my ear is
the spacer bad fielder pattern or
something like it with with I can
structure can signal processing we can
have in adaptive beamforming we can have
the main loop to be much narrower than
the spatial match filters main loop so
so so with with some adaptive signal
processing be informing techniques we
can actually make the main loop to be to
be to be much much much much sharper
than those this is um this is spatial
match filtering kind of
cool the delay and some performer yeah
it's pretty much at the length of your
phone and you cannot help you go a
little bit beyond epic tale media and
that's first of all the activity bottom
that's it for sensors that the the kind
of informing you mentioned I mean this
would be a subclass of the kind of
beamforming that that you mentioned even
with just the delay in sump informer if
we pay the delay and and the waste
properly we can make the main beam beam
with to be much much sharper than Matt
filtering kind of beam width so well the
sensitivity of any one of the velocity
sensors is a figure like the best
authority
and you're never going to get to
directivity there's any sharper than a
figure of eight that's that's your limit
in fact the jobs you can do is is to
create a hyper-cardioid
right that's that's the disk limit you
need to have a higher order sensor
okay so sharp authority
the kind of thinking that that I have
maybe it is not correct i am a
participatory in storming is that yeah
that is the pin panel of an individual
sensor but we have several of them and
if we pay the summing weight wisely
their composite the entire arrays
composite beam pattern can be much
sharper it's a little bit like the UL a
uniformly knee array of iso shopping
sensors each of the individual sensor
has no directivity at all but if we have
a ula and pick the beam weights wisely
the entire array can have a very short
can ever so much sharper main loop so i
don't know we talked about the same
thing we're actually going to have a
chat later so maybe we prevent you
remember that's it so if you've got
these these three finger lakes that are
orthogonal to one another so you've got
a case where you got incoming wave this
is coming from this direction you're at
the nulls of two of them so the only
sensors is going to give you any
information is the one that whose main
lobe is is aligned with income way
that's the limit of your directivity but
how about the other two senses become
useless in that case okay if you're the
only Mike you can go a little bit cuz i
get the only then you get a B+ yeah yes
that's it from four point we'll go to
six degree Vivian please know that
that's why he's young because if he has
a lot of one so the interference is
going to have so you know I'm pretty
that's what it puts another session at
now there's a place where the gain is
going to be huge Valle's your absolute
limit you're not going to be better yeah
but I'm saying like if you if you send
them figure out it being your place or
there's nothing and in such a way that
then though is in your interference okay
yeah if yet you stayed that the null is
steeper than never yes you showed up to
your statement zoomy zoom zoomy us is
for the guys yet if you have won a
interfering source is multiple it Alton
Alton yes dear you had one source of
point
if you wanted to measure the directivity
pattern of the resulting system is never
going to be any greater than the
director new passenger anyone for my
friends another blank blank blank be
great student
right right right well but but but my
question is given for the ula ula of
isotropic senses even if we just have
one source and we want to state what's
the source by YC picking the pin for my
weight we can still have a very high
gain towards the source look direction
so so the kind of beam former if we also
use some kind of I mean if we use also
do some help in former and paid-up
informal ways wisely for the three
components in the velocity sensors triad
can we actually have sharper team
towards the dirty side of direction
but the for the item shopping for kids
but before the glow a case learn the
noise thanks to which wider than of the
directions
for this reason
right Thank You away theme would still
be narrower than any one individual as a
Sharpie sensors gain so so for the you
Lak so so by doing the signal processing
wisely we can add a little bit more gain
beyond the gain of an individual sensor
array of this type of sensors means
stopping point 11 then the three the
Triad is on three hours on a orthogonal
coordinate system for you la is both in
sensors are the same you're my sister so
if you combine multiple basically the
same coordinate axes you can get
benefits like save the data and spatial
diversity that this doesn't have
actually 22 special attentions they
actually to this is the estimate in
elevation so they're actually two and
two independent coordinates spatially
speaking azimuth and elevation and we
have three of them three sensors now I
would agree with you if the soil just
happen to be exactly parallel to the I
mean the no x axis y z axis yeah the
other to basically give us zero response
so that's basically no matter what being
from the ways we pay it's basically no
effect but how about a more general
situation which is not exactly parallel
to the x-axis why you see X's then we
have three sensors but two direction of
a rifle coordinates azimuth and
elevation since the big advantage
to your source so just because it's in
3d doesn't make it any less in 2d array
imagine you had two figures of eight and
the non people mm-hmm you can steer a
hyper-cardioid of car do whatever you
can steer that so any angle you like but
that that the the the directivity index
doesn't change with angle it doesn't
matter if it's completely aligned with
one or being alive in the other the
directory in dec stays the same and that
directivity index is limited by the
directive dapat nerve of any one of the
senses but when we do beamforming with
the villa san Estrella we're not this is
just rotating it we also making one of
them larger relative to the other ones
this is not this lateral rotation same
thing could be a normalization terminus
to the rotation
okay I I need to look more into but um
how do you achieve more than first or
the directivity when you have only first
of all the direction that are co-located
different if you had them in two
generations but this is at one point in
space my my palm with the discussion
right now is that I would need to have a
mathematical definition of directivity I
mean I I mean because they did I mean I
need to have the precise definition my
impression is that we might be using the
same term slightly differently autumn is
your gayness functional intellectually
duration yes yes yes I understand it but
but when we talk about the triad then
the type activity of the entire triad
and a directivity of an individual
velocity sensor you know then this this
is dinner I don't quite follow you your
reasoning but now I'll thing more about
that and any more questions you showed a
whole bunch of commercial velocity and
triads what processing nails compares
you actually only show one carissa one
the microphone and I think they
basically just make the product they are
not into devising beamforming algorithms
as far as I know there are some papers
that use the microphone in some field
testing open arrow endure testing and
those people some of them are later
Michael Fong some of them are not
related I'm offhand I don't remember
what kind of algorithm they use for the
UIUC University of Illinois
urbana-champaign one that Professor
basically and its graduates to basically
just build a system they just build a
system not not they seem to be part 2
well developed over thought about do you
know what processing they use can't idea
but most of them questions